the vendors have increased but the
number of buyers is decreasing
used clothes and shoes are sold at this
roadside market which has been here for
decades but business is not what it used
to be
i have been selling used shoes for a
long time it is only this year when
prices have showed up so high that there
are no customers people have no
purchasing power i'm struggling to feed
the children
the pakistani rupee is at its lowest
against the dollar and commodity prices
at their highest in 70 years
to keep the economy afloat the
government has borrowed from allies like
saudi arabia as well as loans from the
international monetary fund
facing a double whammy of austerity and
inflation people are complaining about
essentials being too expensive from food
to fuel and utilities including
electricity
i've had a lot of hope in prime minister
imran khan's government but we've been
totally disappointed even people like us
who have never had to look for bargains
in the street are struggling to afford
basics
political parties in the opposition have
called their supporters to the streets
in protest against inflation and say
they will march to the capital if the
economy continues to decline
pakistan's rate of inflation has risen
in the last few years to 9.7 percent in
the last three years the prices of basic
food items have skyrocketed a kilo of
sugar now costs 90 cents instead of 35 a
liter of milk costs 70 cents instead of
55 and the basic staple a bag of flour
is at three dollars instead of two
the government says the price of wheat
in pakistan is half of what it costs in
neighboring india and bangladesh and it
blames a global increase in oil prices
for the surge in fuel and electricity
charges currently our country is in a
state of hyperinflation there are many
reasons behind it but one of the most
important reason and the most visible
reason that one can identify is the
incompetency of our government
not the case says the prime minister
imran khan blames the previous
governments for the current economic
troubles
i'm happy to announce the biggest
welfare program in pakistan's history
yes there is inflation in the country
but we should also look at what the
government is doing to alleviate the
situation
but near the prime minister's house
buyers and sellers in islamabad's used
items market say their incomes are no
match for pakistan's inflation
islamabad